wait so that was actually gonna be my
next question what is your advice for
like what what your clients what type of
men do you advise that they go for
high value high value only
no I I titled this how to find high
value event but it was clickbait I'm
sorry guys
oh yeah
yeah a little bit subjective in a way
and not in a way I get it I'm not trying
to be social constructivist up in here
because the a woman who is with a
plumber who is making 80 000 a year who
is very influential and fit she could
think he's a high value man I think all
that matters they're like is your man
high value to you you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah yeah so
what the problem that I run into with my
clients is that they don't know that
their lists are so picky okay they are
very disillusioned with what man really
is and what I mean is
they ask for what sounds I ideal right
so like I want him to be funny I want
him to be intelligent I want him to be
ambitious I want him to be fit I want
him to make typically six figures
they're not saying six figures they just
say that they want to have kids and they
want to be emotionally intelligent and
yeah so they think that that's not a lot
I'll tell you right now that's a damn
unicorn because you have to make some
comfort oh what do they want to they
want that he's young so if you if you
look at my relationship there's
definitely compromises that I made but I
I find that to be okay so for example
one of the compromises I made is he's
twice my age yeah that's my age you know
like tell me that's not a compromise now
granted I don't really get along much
with Millennial men
um but that's because they have like a
masculinity crisis and I'm not I'm not
going to teach you how to be a man like
I'm trying to have a lumberjack so
um I tell them to date based off of
three values because
values is what's going to make a
marriage work versus preferences a
preference is that he's six foot tall
that he's funny that he's emotionally
intelligent like what if the man who is
going to hold you down for the rest of
your life and is a good person maybe he
comes from baggage maybe he's got Mama
issues maybe he uh had some things come
up in his life so he never got to reach
his absolute full professional potential
things like one of his parents got
cancer so he had to drop out of school
or something like you just never know so
pick a guy off of three values three
values that I could say that I would
have for myself
is that I I do want a man that is fit
okay that that's just I'm sorry can't
can't cap on that and I want a man who
is going to be doesn't need to be
emotionally intelligent but is just
willing to be able to sit there with me
in my feelings like don't need the input
just need to know that he's gonna be
able to tolerate when I'm emotional and
the other piece is that he's going to be
able to provide enough for me to be able
to stay home and raise small children
and do I plan on working with my
children older yes so those are those
are things that I value and really it's
like providing for the for the children
like that's just valuing family and
emotional compatibility and is he sexy
so three values that's it that's all you
need you don't need this list of 10 10
20 30 items I used to think that these
red pill dudes were tripping until I
started working with women and I found
out they were they were telling the
truth really oh my gosh I just started
doing one-on-one sessions with people
I've only had men sign up but
I would I don't know do I want do I want
to work with women is it
no how can I do this so I work with
women because I want to make I want to
help well-rounded women and because I
didn't have any guidance
um on what it means to be a woman who
who has the ability to have optimal mate
selection which is that's what I was
trying to do so I I don't really coach
going for profit the only reason why I
charge women is because sometimes in
order for somebody to do the work they
have to pay for it because if you do
things for free people just can't see
the value I can't tell you because at
the very beginning I would help women
and give them advice for free but I was
realizing it was taking like two or
three hours out of my day to help these
women that they don't really want to
help themselves so when you set a price
it's a it's a bar of and yeah yeah yeah
so they have a little bit of skin in the
game and even then like sometimes
they're just not committed so I I say
that I I coach women to learn more about
empathy it's not necessarily profitable
most likely the most money I'm going to
be making is off of YouTube If I wanted
to make money with women I would tell
them what feels good right all the most
successful femininity coaches that I
know there are there like they have the
stuff to back it up for example married
18 years well-rounded children but in
reality the ones that I see that hit it
big
they don't even have the relationship to
co-sign and and so it's like you're
getting advice from women who have been
single for 20 30 years they can tell you
how to get a man but most of them can't
tell you how to keep a man oh my gosh I
the never settle like what what do you
mean never settle who are you looking
for like the perfect like
you can't settle a little bit like not
even I mean it's crazy
so you you had that girl that said that
she wanted a 200 000 engagement ring oh
my
God I did you see my face when she said
that I was like
ma'am from who from who and this is the
crazy thing my my brother's uh my
younger brother just out of college
guarantee he'll be making six figures in
five years hardest worker ever met older
brother makes six figures my dad
multi-millionaire I'm like okay lady
don't you want to ask me like I know
these men that like make this money I'm
like none of them if they're if they're
any of their fiances or like my dad you
know my mom said can I have a two
hundred thousand dollar engagement ring
you know what that none of them would
get the guy none none of them would
spend that girl no check it out if you
know what it is it's people that haven't
been around money so they don't know how
money works so you your father is a top
half of one percent earner so you know
that even though he makes as much money
as he does he ain't buying no no a
hundred thousand dollars two hundred
thousand dollar ring that's the thing
women think when it comes to high value
men he's gonna send me on trips to Dubai
I'm gonna have a Gucci bag like honey I
was getting a dress at Goodwill last
week the only way the high value man
keeps the money is if you know how to
how to not waste it well and it's and
it's a value because men who value fam
like my dad my whole life he said I just
want to pay for my kids college I was
stuck in debt for like 10 years I don't
like is he that that's where all of that
was like his life's goal was to pay for
all of our colleges it wasn't
you know pay for my mom to do nothing
all the time and that's that's the thing
if you marry a hard worker he's going to
expect you to work whether it's at the
house with the kids like you you are not
going to be doing nothing I guarantee
that oh I'm telling you yeah so like as
fun as YouTube is I mean really I just
what I wanted to do I'm an experimenter
like I said before so I wanted to see
like what's up with this algorithm I
can't really figure this out turns out I
can turns out I can but now that I've
committed myself to the internet I kind
of got to stay here but my fiance let's
say I didn't want to do YouTube I would
probably be running marathons because
that's just who I am I want to do
something with my free time I don't care
if I'm sitting here making making
knickknacks for my house I'm gonna do
something so you can't just sit at home
and twiddle your thumbs and then a lot
of women too it's amazing how they get
overwhelmed with housewife work like we
got air fryers and we got roombas and we
got Windex like imagine having to clean
windows before Windex was on the scene
like I am not trying to hear these women
oh my God this is how to say I'm like
can we return our rights like can we can
we can we give them back because I'm
like guys everything's automated now we
fumbled a bag like we could have just
you know
Ali long says that feminism was one of
the worst things to ever happen to women
because it's like we told we told men
the secret that we can do everything
that they can do